a S m R:
bop:
(why are we still here)
*scream in swedish*
True Felix: Hell yeah!
*clap*
It's time for another week of
LWIAY
Where I go through your submissions you ask the content. I have the questions.
Roll the intro
Let's see what you posted to this week's.
I wOndER iF thEre's GoING to BE Any CHAIR MEMES in there
I did I did recently break out of prison you are correct
who would win I have better graphism
but can you *laughs* do this
Wow
Could barely even get started
Logan Paul makes a video showing a dead body YouTube puts it in the trending list PewDiePie makes a 15 second re-
response video that doesn't show a dead body. Violates Terms of Service
I'm not gonna call out YouTube
for their blatant
favoritism
when in fact the people
reuploading logan paul's video got taken down and flagged with a strike
But Logan Paul's video was approved and not even age restricted. That's not favoritism. That's just uh-
that-
I- I'm just I'm just glad YouTube is keeping you know the same rules for everyone
It makes sense it seems fair to me
I'm sure Logan Paul's show "The Thinning" will be canceled just like I- my show was cancelled as soon as
media attention gone into
somebody toucha ma idea *laughs*
I love how I've been seeing this meme just appear in a lot of different places I saw it on Twitter
*all star by smash mouth intro* some-
-BODY TOUCHA MA SPAGHET
somebody toucha my spaget
skrattar du: me förlorar du: also me *laughs*
Just can't help yourself I gotta say these are pretty good memes you guys are learning you guys are improving
You're like you're like an AI you can be taught well done
my heart: resting
exercising:
When somebody toucha your spaget:
Take all these horrible things that happen sexual harassment, murder
But it went someone toucha your spaget, that's when you know you have to stand up and use your voice
SOMEBODY TOUCHA MY SPAGET
Ethan and Post did it before goddamnit. Oh, yeah. Oh yeah
but can hE DO THIS?
EH? EH? I DON'T THINK SO EYYUGHHHHEH *gibberish in swedish*
Learn the difference. Learn the difference, this is a high quality
399 dollar chair
okay. how much you pay for your apple products , huh? huh?
Certainly a nice chair isn't so expensive is it
fuckin-
hypocritical scumbags
real-life doki-doki, I gently open the- nooo aww huh huh
I feel like we're gonna see these meme for a long time a long time, it's a
2018 uh- is a good start of the oh my door is ringing excuse me
'scuse me while i open my door
*buy the chair, so YoU cAn dO tHiS*
*clears throat*
wait I don't need this
Yeah explain this YouTube huh why you touching my sPAGET
SPAGET
That's pretty cool. I love the design so much. I put it on my nails. Very nice. You know this is
high-quality design by yours truly
pewwwwwdiepiee
and have you seen my chair *laughs*
it's 399
You're welcome
Marzia and Felix don't work out. I think I found pewdiepie's go to girl
Why?
Because she has a sledgehammer everybody great. It's definitely Brad
how to talk to short people wrong correct
hey Marzia I wanna talk to you
Realizing you're halfway through the video, and you don't know what the f it's about because you've been looking at the LEDs
lights for seven minutes straight
That's that's good to know that my channel is full of audience of intellectuals
Who's not just distracted by blinking lights
I'm trying to put forth the nice message here about the 2017
and you're just like oh look shiny!
who would win a one wide boi or one long boi
oh yeah?
But can wide boi do
THIS- aghh
Hopefully one day my back will just crack and that'll be my final video
*laughs* of the internet
Okay, we have uh huh, okay?
oh...
Somebody toucha my spaget
chikachikachic- break it down now girl now
*beat drops*
Yeah, you know what I can do that if I want to
look
I'm doin it
*laughs* I won most handsome 2017 number six on trending. the worst gift of
2017 number seven and twenty on trendy
that's right everybody youtube's favorite show confirmed LWIAY
LWIAY much better than ya, whatever I can't even say it cuz it's such a bad name
I don't know how you come up with such a terrible unoriginal name LWIAY is
supreme
Champion, thank you
I don't really feel comfortable letting other people do stuff for me yet makes billions and millions by letting fans do his work
Imagine killing yourself and Logan Paul is the one that finds your body I'd kill myself again *laughs*
It's over Anakin. I have the high ground.
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS
*hysterical laughter*
*claps* yes
*inhales* that's good
It's over Anakin. I have the high ground.
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS
AYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYY-HEY
Got him, good. Got him, good. Any time you're losing an argument in anything if you realize
ah shitttt uhh
I'm- I'm probably gonna have to use my trump card. Can you do this? GAH
Ah these Logan memes are good someone hanged herself recently. I was pretty bummed out about it, but the total views on my channel increased so whatever
*clap*
oh the memes
Are they taste- they taste so good
like someone's
SPAGET
Uhhh when you go from being Internet's number one hated youtuber to Internet's second most hated youtuber *laughs*
men women deficient *laughs* pewdiepie
GOD DAMNIT
400 dollars- 400
three ninety nineeeeeeeeeee
just 399 bebeh
smile sweet sister sadi- oh no oh no
Logan why LWIAY Logan LWIAY
LWIAY
My drawing thank you for being yourself we love you #pewdiepie #brofist HolmesDraws that's sick very nice
smile
sweet
sister
sadistic
suprise
service
SOMEBOD- YES
somedody toucha ma spaghet
I KNEW IT *inhales* oh
Did anyone else learn math with these in elementary school we had these for the special kids in class
*inhale* respect the wahmen after all he's nice guy pewdiepie of course of course
guys I am the nicest of the nicest
I am the top ten of the nicest if there was a top ten nicest guy PewDiePie list I'd definitely be top ten
top tennnn
Babe I need some money
hELL NO *laughs*
this fuckin image is so bad
god damnit
hELLNO
This is family friendly Christian content, right? yep. And it doesn't break YouTube guidelines? nope.
Then if I publish it it won't get demonetized? that makes sense to me. publish. DEMONETIZED
YES YES
*claps* CLAP
so annoying
It's like Oh. Everything is fine. I'm just gonna publish this now, I sure hope nothing bad happens
ʰᵒʷˢ ᶦᵗ ᵍᵒᶦⁿ ᵇʳᵒˢ ᵐʸ ⁿᵃᵐᵉ ᶦˢ ᵖᵉʷᵈᶦᵉᵖᶦᵉ ᵃⁿᵈ ʷᵉˡᶜᵒᵐᵉ ᵗᵒ is it LWIAY
LW A A A A AY *laughs*
Logan- Oh my god *laughs*
That's a good meme right there
Anyway that was another week of SPAGET remember to submit your memes in the pewdiepie submission subreddit
It's the greatest subreddit of all time. This is literally repeat this week with 20,000. That's insane
The memes are getting better. I'm not gonna lie the memes are getting better
Okay, we need more chair
I mean less chair memes and more original content Who am I kidding? That's never gonna happen?
Thank you for watching another one leave a like if you enjoy and a squad fam out